I never want to do this again so this is
the bits and bobs box 3/4 an inch turn
in all around what does it mean when you
say to turn in all around okay so this
is way better than if my kid I've done
this so I'm feeling good about this
right now
here it's it I told ate the minute this
is disgusting I'm disgusting I tape this
too high it's okay I'm a fucked-up
racket after watching you I need to
strategize was this vaguely at all what
I was supposed to do
yes that was exactly do what on the
other side this a problem I no offense
to you this would be you know more fun
with my kid you're not folding so I need
I did I mention I was crappy at crafts
are there any like tacos like Barrett at
home I don't know where the hole is you
take the scissors away from her I don't
even want to put in the effort anymore
don't give up or cheats the final
countdown sort of a box of haha this is
Bobby's but perfect the Box had ever
seen for your bits and in Bob I got a
little bored of it I mean oh she gave up
let's be honest okay mother
what do you have
they made a penis if the box is going
straight - pictures is cool but a lot of
the ideas are not reasonable for drunk
people
my name's Pete